ecco questo è prima nel concetto di
pompa solo po strano cene se il frate
sei diventato uno snow relax cento
da adesso in avanti non voglio più
incontrare snor l'ex per strada neanche
in poche mondo sono due salsa anche lo
zio addio a dire ci sono i box garris
harry bari genchi non fa qui
oddio più più di ti sei fatto qualche
canna nel frattempo ha gli occhi rossi
nono è il massimo posto al quale sia
marian è arrivato su sluyter io mai
arrivato così avanti
[Musica]
figlio di tua madre che si deve infilare
nel deretani vermi da buttare giù sito
ufficile non miracoli
no no salve cipro stai calmo ma che
cazzo sei di clet pokémon che mi spunti
al pavimento
ce lo dico alla maestra per aprire la
finestra la finestra quella laida di tua
madre che batte in autostrada e lo
sapevo io che sarebbe successo
la ragazza non mi ha visto
stavo scherzando mi ha visto la cosa più
romantica che io abbia mai visto in un
videogame andando a fare il bagno
insieme a quanto possono essere teneri
[Musica]
cosa stai facendo da un'ora e mezza cioè
di giorno che cazzo ma cosa sto giocando
poco e la presa per il culo lo so non
capisco farà come ridotta a casa nostra
bastardi modo in alto abbiamo messo una
vita
e voi negli hotel a cinque stelle e
renzi dove non ho capito febbraio però
c'è e non corri perché non corre perché
non corra il mio personaggio di festa
perché non corre porca [ __ ] che ancora
ci fa o ci provo è mica frate dovrei
andare su saturno
[Musica]
no vabbè altre lo giuro che ho provato
sterzare ma nostra vita niente inutile
43 mila iscritti potrò farmela la foto
non sei abbastanza famose grazie dice
perché ti spacco la mascella
ma come to the limbo che mancava il
banco su cammina dritto io lo fa limbo
ma sei stupido nel cervello savonese
notiamo gli archi al 9 estrarne o non è
male
e questa la bambola gonfiabile eccoti
che minchia che seguito maurizio merli a
the nation cava niente ti ha ucciso di
buongiorno prova perché ho detto che
sono arrivato in ritardo prima
erano soltanto tre minuti dal botto mi
dispiace posso chiederti una roba è
giusto perché no scherzavo se vuoi non
senti offendi non ti chiedo niente
finito è sfogato i tuoi istinti umani
anche se non sei un caso umano prova beh
si è offeso
ma [ __ ] f meno ai odiato la
matematica così tanto che hai lasciato
la scuola otto anni la storia della mia
vita senza lode a dio po di te giocato
fuoco brucia cookies baseman che le
bombe tel
non vi preoccupate ragazzi sono lo
conoscevate suo sito non lo conoscevo
mango io con e odio
fuori fuori infilato nell'ano ecco
ragazzi è l'unico gioco della storia
perché un video né appena cascato sul
mio paraurti che cazzo succede ma sei
scemo mandava quelle tuo occhio non
dovrei mangiare fratello è non va bene
che ti magico io non solo è un cane
cinese e pur ubriaco
stare a roma ieri vaio
l'arma e dica che tu e voglio che il
board game presto ban giusto polfer is
no ok a [ __ ] va a fargli di sì è vero
l'ha detto sul serio salve mi scusi lei
che che sicura è che cazzo
ma perché va che si sta roba
[Applauso]
la pace può accompagnare solo che cazzo
rivi questa è una faccia di uno che ride
e la faccia
questo è l'armadietto di uno che ride
younger style o punk adam st ma quanta e
trash sto gioco quanto è diventato figo
sto gioco perché non l'ho più giocato ho
trovato il libro la scuola uccide ti ho
detto io e david vuoi dirmi che tipo non
riesce a raggiungermi perché io sono
soprattutto
in stallo ribelli che c'hai sul tetto
liberati male stavi aspettando per farmi
incazzare di la verità
l'attuale interessi di essere visibile
ma avere il cazzo piccolo e che senso ha
poi se poi sei milioni e cercasse
gigante che giuliante ha spesso successo
michael jackson e cassette
scherzavano incanto più voi francesi del
cazzo credete di essere più che paga
veterano sci fi e cosa cioè iscrivetevi
minchioni è che palle sarà un successo
con il libro stai calmo mi capita anche
a me di esser contento dei vivi
dovrebbero dio mio no così chochina
cazzo fai frate posso farti una domanda
così facendo di quella [ __ ] labbra
fari si si si cimenterà nel concerto
numero 5 mai la vj grazie
[Musica]
sono forte vodka tram o cazzo scherzavo
signor trump non le sa ecco bravo apra
la bocca perfetto perfetto quanto trash
questa scena santo iddio assente quando
ho sentito il profumo di vodka
spalancato la bocca e momento della
madonna di squarto tutta la famiglia di
44 dj siamo due ragazzi di 16 anni il 2
2 che non mi stavo vantando di avere 16
anni due ragazzi di 16 anni e facciamo i
video o finalmente grazie dio è la
madonna intriso di sei volte giu e giù
per oggi sono lottatissimo lo salvò
giornate neanche per il cazzo sono salvo
manco fuga sulla mancava ma poco un
passo ma neanche un po un laccio di
scarpe ed era arrivato al 6 point ma
neanche quello